here's a story from cnr.com Governor
Abbott Texas right to self-defense
supersedes any federal statutes to the
contrary Texas governor Greg Abbott
invoked America's founding fathers while
vowing to continue to secure Texas's
Border in a new statement his message
comes two days after the United States
Supreme Court ruled the federal
government could remove Razer wire along
the Rio Grand installed by the state to
deter illegal immigration and drug
trafficking as the Biden
administration's appeal makes its way
through the court Texas respond fed by
installing more razor wire on January
23rd quote the federal government has
broken the compact between the United
States and the states the executive
branch of the United States has a
constitutional duty to enforce federal
laws protecting States including
immigration laws on the books right now
President Biden has refused to enforce
those laws and has even violated them
Abbott says Biden has smashed records
for illegal immigration and ignored
Texas's demand that he perform his
constitutional duties
continuing President Biden has violated
his oath to Faithfully execute
immigration laws enacted by Congress
instead of Prosecuting immigrants for
the federal crime of illegal entry
President Biden has sent his lawyers
into federal courts to sue Texas for
taking action to secure the Border
President Biden has instructed his
agencies to ignore Federal statutes that
mandate the Detention of illegal
immigrants the effect is to illegally
allow their nmass parole into the United
States by wasting taxpayer dollars to
tear open Texas's border security
infrastructure President Biden has
enticed illegal IM immigrants from the
28 legal points of Entry along the state
Southern border Bridges where nobody
drowns and into the dangerous water of
the Rio Grand White House Press
Secretary Karine Jean Pierre told
reporters during a briefing on January
23rd the Biden Administration was
certainly glad the Supreme Court had
permitted the federal government to
remove the razor wire which she called
ineffective approximately 6 million
illegal immigrants have entered the
United States during Biden's three years
in office so what we're seeing right now
New York is freaking out Eric Adams says
the immigration crisis will destroy the
city mayor Brian Johnson has been
accused reportedly there's a reporter
who has asserted I'm very careful my
language here he has suffered panic
attacks and had to be hospitalized
because the immigration crisis or as the
immigration crisis is expanding rapidly
in the city and there are many
communities in Chicago many black
communities that are in uproar over the
resources being given out to these
migrants so when you have Ma major
Democrat strongholds outraged over the
immigration crisis Joe Biden publicly
admitting the border is not secure while
actively trying to make it less secure I
don't know what you call this a rogue
executive branch engaged in criminal
activities Accused by Texas the second
largest state in the Union of violating
the
law now we have videos let me see if I
can uh uh pull up one of these these
videos here there's the uh the letter
here we go take a look at this from
Chuck kesto the Texas National Guard
filmed marching where I can only I I
believe this is near Eagle Pass it just
says Texas National Guard and uh there
have been many responses to this in fact
I I believe we have the uh Governor
Kevin stit of Oklahoma saying Oklahoma
stands with Texas Ronda santis of course
said if the Constitution really made
States powerless to defend themselves
against an invasion it wouldn't have
been ratified in the first place and
Texas would have never joined the union
when it did Texas is upholding the law
while Biden is flouting it Florida will
keep assisting Texas with personnel and
assets so this is going to get
interesting where are we currently at
three states Florida Oklahoma and Texas
are aligned Texas is declaring Supremacy
over the Border
jurisdiction the question then that
we've been asking for the past several
days will the federal government
actually make move moves against the
Texas National
Guard I I don't think so I I showing the
Oklahoma and Florida are willing to
stand by the Texas National Guard and
the Texas government is is fulfilling
and it's also indicative that like any
state that sits by and watches their
federal government sees control of their
own State troops has got to be like hell
no you can't we can't let the federal
government go rogue rogue is a nice term
can't let the federal government
overstep its bounds and seize our own
State soldiers like those guys pledge an
oath to the state to defend and preserve
the state not they're not the federal
government's troops I'm not sure if if
not if the guard does that or not I
don't know how Constitution most likely
but the the the federal government is
Rogue completely yeah the Biden
Administration is is a rogue agency at
this point this is this is I am this is
a fact when the Biden Administration is
breaking the law to the extent that
Democrats are upset about it despite the
fact they'll defend him for re-election
because these people are insane but when
you have major cities there there there
is a a plurality of those ped saying
immigration is the most pressing issue
yeah and people in these cities that are
Democrat left leaning are freaking out
this is this is the unifying force I
mean perhaps we're we're getting Joe
Biden's pulling off an azi mandas for
those who get the reference he is
deciding to become the super villain
that will unify blue and red States
against him maybe maybe by the time the
election comes up the immigration
problem will will be so bad that States
will beg Donald Trump to help save them
maybe somebody is doing that through
Biden they're creating an azy mandia
situation where like we're just going to
make Biden the worst of the worst so
that we can actually unify the country
cuz Trump ain't getting it done for
those that don't know the reference azy
mandas is the villain in the Watchmen
graphic novel who stages an alien
invasion to force the Cold War Nations
to unite against a common enemy and so I
don't believe that to be the case I
don't believe that there is anybody
smart enough or I I I genuinely believe
this is completely in line with what
Democrats have been doing for some time
and even though you have blue cities in
major blue States in uproar over this
these people are still blaming
Republicans and they're still backing
Joe Biden I talked to my parents and I
bring them up as just kind of General
Normie watch the MSNBC but they're very
smart they're very adaptable to new
information but they tend to watch just
the TV instead of the internet for their
news they don't and uh I was like this
this migrant this immigration thing is
horrific and they're like yeah it is
horrific
both of them and they get their news
from like MSNBC but they were like is
Absolut it's too far like what in the
hell is happening kind of thing
like easily that I could I could
probably convince them to not vote for
the guy that's causing it to happen this
is going to be the issue that I think
jenz is going to really wake up to too
because once they see that these
immigrants are the ones that are taking
spaces in America taking over the cities
our cities are increasing in crime and
your tax dollars are directly funding
the immigration crisis as well I mean
Texas had no other choice but to enact
Article 1 Section 10 in the Constitution
because the federal government isn't
doing anything about it and honestly the
federal government hates American people
more than Democrats I think hate
American people because they're the ones
that are creating this havoc in our
country and I mean I saw a poll that
immigration is a bigger issue going into
the election cycle more than inflation
and I mean we're seeing inflation rat
Skyrocket but I think people are finally
starting to understand like oh my gosh
our border really is open and what
Kareem John Pierre uh PRC said if it was
ineffective then why move it inflation
is a byproduct of immigration yeah Mass
migration results I mean look by by by
standard economics Mass migration they
even say it will create demand so you're
going to have a ton of people demanding
more and more and more you're going to
drive prices up but the the best way to
explain it we talked about this before
and you can give me your thoughts as
someone who is Gen Z I watched this
video where it was this gen Z guy being
like welcome to a New York micro
apartment $2,000 a month for like 70
square ft it's a it's it's five 5 1/2 ft
wide and like and 10 ft deep so we're
talking like you know 55 square fet and
it's got a sink no bathroom nothing else
a single window and if you want to use
the bathroom it's shared in the hallway
two grand $2,000 per month and so I I I
think what we're seeing now the reason
why Donald Trump is getting a lot of
genz support and he is several polls
have him up with genz which is crazy
look if you're a boomer it's real easy
to be a boomer and have access to wealth
on average Boomers have more access than
gen Z does for obvious reasons you're
older you've got a savings you got a
retirement or something so you're likely
living in a house or an apartment or
condo or something like that gen Z is
trying to move into places and they're
running up against the wall they can't
afford it at the same time they can't
afford it guess what's happening in New
York City illegal immigrants are being
given hotel rooms they're giving they're
given free money free places to stay now
imagine this imagine you're 22 24 hey
you are 24 you're fresh out of college
you got a degree like they told you to
get you can't find a job and you're
standing outside in W with your little
you know attache case holding your
resumés and there's an illegal immigrant
buying free food and going into their
hotel room with a bed a TV a bathroom
and security private security and you're
like maybe if I'm lucky I can get one of
those shoe box pods to live in you know
what's going to happen they're going to
be like I'm voting for Donald Trump it's
the you will own nothing and be happy
mentality because when you get an entire
generation who simply cannot afford on
their salaries to even save up money to
then even invest in property they're
going to rent for the rest of their
lives and it's true I mean these
immigrants are getting everything handed
to them I mean now in New York free
health care uh in California you have
medical where 700,000 migrants were
approved to get free taxpayer dollar
paid Healthcare I mean these people are
walking across the border without
absolutely no consequences with what a
court date that's 2 years out phones
paid for by us and uh and they're
getting more amenities than your college
graduate who's 60 70 $100,000 in debt
and will never be able to pay that off
we got to do like a I don't know like a
Curb Your Enthusiasm style joke or
something about an illegal immigrant in
this nice hotel with a comfortable bed
and a TV and then the hardworking guy is
like living in the Pod and eating bugs
he hires him to clean his toilet or
something right
right I mean they're living the American
dream more than Americans are yeah it's
really when you see it with your own
eyes is when things start to change like
I can imagine residents in New York
walking down 42nd Street to go to work
where they're being paid like 16 bucks
an hour and they have to step over
homeless people obviously and then you
find out that there's people that don't
speak English staying in these hotels
like I remember in LA in '08 um I had
friends that were illegal immigrants
that were working at the restaurant I
was working at and working in the
environment and they were getting put up
in like $400 a month hotels where I was
paying 1,200 or 1300 a month for mine
and I was just the jealousy that in me
from that was like rampant I could I had
to check myself I'm like no they're
getting an opportunity but if you saw
that in Mass I could imagine like what
in the hell is going on it shouldn't
take one state busing thousands of
people to other states so that way the
other states feel the pain of of the of
the migrants that are coming in to get
the rest of the country to pay attention
and it definitely shouldn't take those
measures to have the federal government
ignore it its its job like the federal
government is supposed to take care of
the borders and it's preventing the
state from from trying to close the
borders that the that the feds refus to
take care of the fact that the the that
the house hasn't drawn up papers of of
Articles of impeachment for for
literally not doing your job the
president ignoring the border the the
the this is this this is this the house
should absolutely have have drawn up
papers absolutely no but but I mean the
federal government is Rogue in it its
entirety the Supreme Court being like no
you can't defend your borders what the
federal government being like we're
going to facilitate human smuggling and
Congress which has a republican
Advantage doing nothing to try and
Corral the corruption thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast
hang out with us live Monday through
Friday at 8:00 p.m. and become a member
over at timcast.net